drapeau flotte
calligraphie et la fierté des
civilisations avec quelques gestes que
j'ai répliqué ici je vous ai apporté
quelque part à casablanca
question de vous raconter un peu
l'histoire de votre merveilleuse langue
savez dans le cas où je suis je suis un
peu obsédé par les lettres
je suis dans l'état où j'écris pour
exprimer tous mes sentiments j'écris
quand je suis content j'écris quand je
suis triste j'ai écrit un peu pour me
connecter à mon histoire dans l'espoir
peut-être de jouer un rôle est de garder
ma langue on vit des fois je suis au
fond de moi pour essayer de trouver un
peu de courage pour juste m'arrêter tu
as tout le monde ils sont en train de
courir il a je m'arrête je vois les gens
en train autour de moi en train de
courir et que vous le lisiez que saab et
vas-y avance colombe annulé je veux
juste voir juste regarder en arrière un
pays
des fois au fond de l'histoire comme ça
j'arrive à voir des choses roulent à
lazarevo voir un peu là pictographique
se transformer en idiot graphie c'est ce
passage en fait caca faciliter le
passage de du symbole à la lettre et je
vois aussi au fond de l'histoire un peu
les araméens en train de sécher leur âge
il est en train de creuser les premières
lettres que l'être humain est connu
rappelle mes semelles il écriture
cunéiforme à 3600 ans avant jésus-christ
je vois un peu encore dans un autre coin
et je vois la ram est en train de
vieillir
alors alors amis et voir son trône
envahir par une nouvelle langue qui
s'appellera tu en as bâti et non bâti en
fait vous devez le connaître
car athènes a bâti a pris 11 ans jour
après jour année après année à
transmettre ces jeunes à son nouveau né
elle l'aura l'arabe est lourd al arabi à
la grande vie en fait à la grandit à la
diva zemin je vais ouvrir et toute la
place elle a envahi toute la place
l'api nationale arrive arabi qui toupet
appris à la senti le besoin de se
diviser en deux stades
regardez-moi ça un train a bâti comme en
essais transformés en rate al arabi elle
a dit je vais me divisé ont des styles
je vais me divisé en confie le coup
fille
c'est un style qui est très difficile de
caractère il et il est dur tandis que
tandis que l'asie c'est un style qui est
docile et les baux facile d'utilisation
mais il a un défaut majeur il n'y a pas
de point sur les lettres et je pense la
majorité d'entre eux ont déjà vu ce
style là il n'y a pas de point sur
l'être et pourtant on lui a décerné un
grand honneur
c'est avec ce style là qu'on a écrit les
premières copies du coran à bout les
assauts de l est n ont à apprendre c'est
le premier qui a eu l'idée de mettre les
points sur les i et sur les battre à
bout la salle et c'est un homme très
intelligent et après abraham d'al-maliki
venons marouane il a ordonné de mettre
des mouvements sur les lettres et vous
savez les mouvements chef bamba et
toutes ces histoires là ça a un rôle
saran l'arabe aussi sophistiquée par
rapport à l'offre aux français et
anglais aux autres langues issu du latin
comme si tu compares un playstation 4
un vieux atari vous rappeler les jeux
d'atari la tiens tu as tu marques des
bus comme ça c'est vrai je vous donne un
petit exemple en fait
mohamed a donné un livre à khaled en
français tu peux dire d'une seule façon
matt gerald e book
tu peux pas changer les lettres ça donne
un autre sens bellarabi à chaque fois tu
vas changer les mouvements sur les
lettres et ça te donne dix possibilités
c'est la langue la plus riche au monde
mais mes frères et soeurs alizés soyez
fiers de notre langue
certains d'entre vous vont me dire
pourquoi ce vieux monsieur dino matou
luis obando avec ces histoires de
devient calligraphie jouer ou dire 'nous
relevons le grand historien il a dit le
maroc il a joué un rôle très important
dans l'épanouissement de la calligraphie
arabe
en fait pendant l'époque des mois et
digne avait une grande bataille car la
calligraphie le le monsieur le confie
dans lequel on a parlé il a voyagé en
fait du coup federer il a fait le saut
acquérant kairouan s'était pas nuit on
bat concurrents allaient tomber ou jamal
le pouvoir l'un d'eux le sais qu'ils me
donnaient malwares
tu vois comment dit la calligraphie est
le voyage avec le pouvoir et après sur
la terre du maroc avait une bataille
féroce entre le coup fidèle aussi le
coup fait kérouané le volet maroc avec
lucho football avant sponsor officiel
final turbine chez nous tuera un final
sur beezik chez nous qui va gagner on
s'en fout bureau choix bastila ushuaïa
chebeya tu vois nulle et ça vous savez
il y avait un épanouissement énorme dans
la calligraphie avec des horaires comme
ça qu'on fait c'étaient des petites
usines pour fabriquer les papiers qu'ils
étaient partout à fès à marrakech par
tous partout ça commence à pousser et on
voit pousser un nouveau style de
calligraphie qui s'appelle elle coud
film arrive elle coud film academy s'est
divisée en cinq styles regardez bien ces
styles que vous voyez tous les jours
devant vous sur le dans les mosquées
dans les journaux tout ça
regardez-moi ça c est normal qu film
tamara ça fait du bien de connaître ces
choses là
mike bliss
phase une chute albi je répète les mêmes
gestes en fait je répète les mêmes
gestes en fait pour que vous comprenez
un peu la technique là je vous ai
emporté quelque part pas loin de là
maintenant la casa blanca avec toute
l'équipe d'aix qui était avec moi je les
de froid pendant la nuit pour faire ces
clichés là alors on applaudit l'équipe
de l'ex s'il vous plaît dans un autre
volet en fait je parlais un peu d'un
truc un peu tu vois si ce jeu parler un
peu de moi j'ai grandi dans une petite
ville en fête
chapelle gaceline une ville triste
pauvre quelque part sur la fonte
frontières de la tunisie de l'algérie en
fait c'est là où ont commencé les
premières émeutes après sidi bouzid
après sa passe et gasnier tout j'ai
grandi là et puis mon père c'était un
homme très respecté dans la ville
c'était un homme tu as comme beau
sourire là je les emmenais la semaine à
passer avant de venir
la maison que vous voyez là c'est la
maison dans laquelle il tenait ces jeux
les emmener un peu sur les traces de son
grand père c'était un homme très
respecté c'était mais il était connu
pour être un homme fidèle à ses
principes ses principes en fait lui ont
coûté cher parce que s'étaient opposés à
ben ali ça nous a coûté très cher nous
vivions constamment dans la terreur ou
la ligue c'était en fait les services de
police au fait ils nous ont rendu la vie
très très difficile j'oublie jamais le
moment on a décidé de fuir toute cette
france là vers l'algérie on a en était
parti en pleine nuit on appris en
autobus après on a pris une voiture de
location après moi et mes petites mais
mes petits frères et soeurs au moins je
prenais un sac j'étais tout jeune et
pillon on a marché pendant 7 km dans la
montagne pour enfin être interpellé par
la police sur la frontière
ils nous ont ramenés je n'oublie jamais
que à 11 ans et il m'invita dans le
poste de police pour me questionner ont
posé de questions je savais rien
je n'avais aucune idée de ce qui se
passait autour de moi j'entends toujours
résonné dans mes oreilles les pleurs de
mes frères et soeurs
les cris de ma mère à chaque fois qu'ils
cassent la porte de la maison en pleine
nuit pour venir chercher mon père
j'avais 11 ans j'étais tout petit et
pourtant j'étais un élève brillant mon
père était très content quand j'ai fini
mes études primaires j'étais
sélectionnée par aller étudier au caire
dans les lycées pilotes
c'est une école pour l'élite en fait
pour les les élèves un peu brillant et
là mon père il me dépose dans cette
ville à 120 km de ma ville natale et se
fit un choc terrible à 11 ans de quitter
ma famille de venir dans un
environnement j'étais très triste je
pleurais tous les jours mais cette panne
risque de s'approfondir t on m'apprend
un jour que mon père a été condamné à 13
ans de prison et c'était mon coeur était
déchirée entre solitude est restée
solitude pourquoi parce qu'il ya
personne qui nous parle en fait personne
ne le parle dans la ville ont marché en
lice étaient comme des fantômes parce
que à chaque personne qui nous parle
c'était un risque pour eux et on vivait
tous seuls et moi tous les jours je pars
et cette position là elle m'est fidèle
j'aime beaucoup je la fais mais
maintenant je me pose sur une petite
colline
je m'isole puis je commence à pleurer
pendant des heures des fois j'ai plus de
l'harmonia abîme je me force supplie de
là mais tu fais quoi je rêve ma tête et
je hais je rêve dans ma solitude
je sors de mon corps et je m'en vante
une vie et je vis cette villa et puis ça
dure pour moi ça dure des décennies
c'était terrible c'était très difficile
pour moi est de retour à la maison après
les vacances c'était la vie n'avait plus
la même définition y avait que deux
lettres de la tristesse entre les murs
les murs il était froid et je trouvais
un petit réconfort à chaque fois que je
me pose devant la bibliothèque de mon
père je regarde ses livres il y avait
des vieux manuscrits pigé le regarde
dont l'espoir de trouver un peu de
sentir son odeur ont peut-être de voir
son sourire est peu à peu j'ai commencé
à ouvrir ses livres là et j'ai commencé
à copier cette écriture là les livres je
comprenais pas grande chose de ce qui
était écrit c'était du style maghribi un
peu tu es un peu bizarre et tout mais là
ces livres là il m'a raconté des belges
thouars ils me disent malige calais
c'est pas grave pas autant père il va
venir un jour c'est pas grave
et j'ai commencé à écrire tout ce que je
faisais c'était écrire tous les jours
tous les jours j'écrivais même dans mon
école j'étais connu pour être kalima
karim le calligraphe et brusquement la
solitude se transforme en qui avait
plein de monde autour de moi ailleurs là
je focalise logement faut que tu vois
bourque et dans 10 ans ils viennent pour
moi mais au moins j'ai du monde autour
de moi
et ces gens là il vient et où et c'est
pour ça que je suis très reconnaissant
envers la calligraphie à la donner un
sens à ma vie
elle peut donner un sens à votre vie car
c'est notre histoire en fait elle peut
donner un sens à votre vie parce que
c'est plus qu'une écriture
c'est notre histoire c'est nos ancêtres
c'est notre vécu et dans le stade où je
suis j'ai c'est de donner à la
calligraphie j'essaie de merger quand
vous voyez des styles anciens du coup
figaro en est avec du street art pourra
les ramener cette calligraphie vers le
monde l'a présenté aux autres j'utilise
du light graff pour faire des
compositions pareil pour montrer que
notre langue elle est belle elle est
magnifique elle est super
fils habib el hayat en 2011
en 2011 il senti le besoin de retourner
à ma ville natale j'ai vécu pendant 15
ans au canada et puis j'ai senti le
besoin de retourner pourra contribuer un
peu et j'ai commencé une série de deux
projets en fait avec les jeunes est le
premier projet je me rappelle ça
s'appelle la révolution ait pris un
groupe de jeunes et puis on était parti
sur les traces des jeunes qui ont été
assassinés pendant la révolution en
tunisie c'était pas loin de la maison de
ma grand-mère et parmi eux parmi ces
gens là y avait mon oncle qui était
décédé et j'étais obligée d'aller écrire
leur lettre dans les mêmes endroits où
il était décidé avec de la lumière
c'était un petit projet mais son impact
était grand karl bien décerné leur jeune
âge au wat pho pablo cote
c'était un truc que j'ai fait avec du
coeur et c'est pour ça que ça a du sens
après j'étais parti avec un groupe de
jeunes comme suite logique à ce projet
là il y en a et en a peint la plus
grande murale de calligraphie ti en
tunisie est l'une des plus grands dans
l'afrique du nord 240 mètres de pure
beauté
on a écrit le poème d'aboul kacem echabi
sur les murs de la prison cette même
prison dans laquelle mon père il a passé
deux ans de sa vie
parmi ces jeunes là parmi ces jeunes là
y'en a qui ont contribué à casser cette
même mur à la pendant la révolution il
était là pour aller la reconstruire
parce qu'ils étaient prêts d'aller
reconstruire leur pays et j'étais très
sélectif j'ai passé quatre mois à
sélectionner le poème je vous jure
quatre mois a sélectionné le poème
j'ai choisi le point d'abord calmés
chaabi ce poète qui a qui a vécu 30 ans
sur terre mais qui avait un impact
énorme
le poème disait ya bien au mit et
rouille ruia revestois rôle que t'as pas
lire kanka taillefine nassim et wafa
juan cano rebboah fils et ma tournée de
catherine d'achat à to'ata choubi
machhour c'est comme ça que tu es
supposé vivre
ils continuent et continuent mais
brusquement au milieu du poème y
viennent ils
ils arrêtent sec femelles à catane
rabbit hole de cuyo dit ouattara ni les
macchabées local gib à a la note doit
service habile et layadi femme anna
malenfant
c'était un hymne à la vie
c'était un hymne à la vie c'était un
hymne aux jeunes ne pouvait voir sur le
documentaire les jeunes et répété cette
même phrase là et répéter parce que ça
avait du sens ça avait je peux parler de
ça car je vais vous parler car au milieu
de tous ces projets là j'en ai fait
plusieurs est un projet qui me tient à
coeur ça s'appelle non les child
l'homophobie
je rêve dans ma solitude ce projet là en
fait je vais le dédié aux enfants qui
souffrent de souffrance c'était un peu
pour souligner le thème de la solitude
dont souffrent beaucoup de gens dans le
monde car la calligraphie elle m'a donné
une voix m'envoie je la donne aux gens
qui n'en ont pas je te la donne
je te la donne je te la donne ma voix je
la donne au milieu d'enfants des fois
souffrent en silence il y avait personne
pour pour onfray apaiser cette
souffrance-là m'envoie je la donne car
je suis fier de votre de ma langue
toutes les civilisations ont été fiers
de leur langue alors vous le devez être
fiers de votre langue droit devant faire
leur sceptre l'exception allège on n'est
pas fiers de notre langue notre calme
larbins de kalou français mais notre
longue on doit connaître notre notre
histoire
je finis je finis en fait pau geris j'ai
risqué ma vie pour écrire ce truc là un
bel août c'était en pleine nuit avait du
tonnerre partout et j'étais assez serein
pas où il y avait un truc pour attirer
le tonnerre j risquer de mourir en fait
mais j'ai pris le risque pour écrire ce
accord car j'ai souffert en silence et
j'ai souffert tous seuls et à la fin
j'ai pu parler à vous en fait je parlais
à mes ancêtres je vais leur dire au
revoir lundi mme je suis fier de vous
écoutez voilà je suis pas je suis pas
fou mima il m'arrive des fois quand je
vois des livres j'entends jean tulard
adam ils ont passé des nuits à écrire ça
à nous transférer le savoir
l'écriture c'est la moitié du ca va
l'écriture c'est la moitié du savoir ils
ont gaspillé leur vie c'est pas gaspé
mais ils ont passé leur vie pour nos
transférer sa il m'arrive des fois
d'écouter le bruit dans leur cas la main
pleine nuit sur les pages des livres je
sors la nuit avec m'allume est arrivé à
chaque fois que je la bouche je vois des
fois leurs visages passé devant moi
d'agir lorsque je fais un truc de
théâtre mais malice je vais le redire
leur dîme je suis fier de vous êtes vous
fier de moi
merci beaucoup
lundi